[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
i'm delighted to say that our brilliant
guest today is a psychoanalyst and a
tavistock whistleblower
marcus evans welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me
it is great to have you on i've given
you a slightly tantalizing introduction
there
uh for any of our viewers who may not be
familiar with tavistock or
you know the article you've written in
colette or any any other work that
you've done publicly just tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that leads you
to be
sitting here talking to two problematic
people like us
okay so i'm a psychoanalyst originally
trained as a psychiatric nurse
worked in psychiatry for over 40 years
and for the last 20 of those in the nhs
i worked in the tavistock as a senior
member of staff part of the management
and then i retired from the nhs
18 months ago and i took up a post as a
governor which is a voluntary post
on the tavistock board of governors and
i resigned
one of the issues that was being
discussed at the time
and we'll get into that in quite a bit
of detail but we have a lot of fans all
over the world so
can you give everybody an idea of what
the significance of the tavistock trust
is in the uk
because there's been several issues that
have come out of that i'm sure we'll
talk about the kiribel case etc
but just give everybody a broad picture
of what we're talking about here
okay so the tavistock is um the smallest
trust
in the nhs so it's a publicly owned
hospital but it's a specialist hospital
insofar as
it's the biggest psychotherapy training
institution in the country and its main
training is in
psychoanalytic psychotherapy and child
psychotherapy
and systemic family therapy that that's
what it's really known for
um in in terms of its history which is
about
80 100 years actually it's it's
centenary
um but so so if you if you picture
although it's a mental health
um trust there aren't beds
and inpatient psychiatric units it's
lots of individual
rooms and group rooms and
people come for treatment on a sort of
session basis
and then you've got a lot of senior
staff and then a lot of trainees
that that's basically the tavis stuff
and it has been embroiled in
a well a scandal is probably the one
wrong word to put it but it is a scandal
of sorts uh around uh the gender
transitioning potential transitioning of
young children and
in particular the kiera bell case could
you dive into that and explain to us
what is happening at the moment
yeah so if you can picture the the sort
of history of the tavistock is in
psychological work
it's not in medication or genetics that
all goes on at the institute of
psychiatry and the maudsley
so this is the the sort of you know it's
psychotherapeutics looking into the
psychological functioning of the mind
but um about 20 years ago
a service was set up called jids
which was an experimental service
basically
seeing kids who were gender dysphoric
and the thing that set it apart from the
rest of the trust
was that there was a sort of recourse to
sort of treating their problems
hormonally
um this was a sort of experimental and
controversial treatment at the time
so in a way it sort of it moved away
from the tavistock's
traditions if you like i mean you know
some kids will be given
um medication but it's not
in the child and family department but
it's not what the tavistock's known for
tavistock's known for psychological work
but this
the jid service was a sort of move away
from that
so how i came to be involved was i i've
been part of the man
i was part of the management for about
20 years i was called the head of
nursing and then i
was in charge of the adult and
adolescent department for about five
years
but my wife worked in in the jit
service about 2005 and she
went into the surface because she was
interested in working at the tavistock
she got another
bit of her job was doing uh training
and she quickly became quite
uncomfortable
with the fact that a lot of kids were
sort of
they come very determined they're very
fixing their view that they're in the
wrong
gender and that they they want to
transition and they want to be given
pills to transition
and the tabletop is the sort of
psychological goat keeper
so you go to the tavistock you're seen
by the sabbath you're assessed there
and then you're moved on to ucl where
the
the hormones are given my wife became
very
unhappy with what was going on back then
marcus sorry to interrupt it would you
keep contracting because i'll carry on
no no but no it's all great i just want
to clarify for the viewers and listeners
when you say kids
how old are these children well
this this whole area has changed
exponentially
so if we went back to the first 30 years
of my time in psychiatry there was small
numbers of people that
transition post 18
mainly male to female sort of
80 85 in the last
15 20 years there's been this
exponential rise
and completely different cohorts
and these are 85 female
to male and they're getting younger and
younger
so i think in her day there are a lot of
15
14 15 16 year olds now you're getting
kids of
10 11 12. so the age at which
kids are wanting to transition get is
getting pushed lower
and the age at which people are prepared
to give hormones has got lower and lower
time and you mentioned that your wife
was becoming increasingly
unhappy at this trend
what was it that she was concerned about
well
basically our usual approach would be to
do a thorough
psychological investigation of what was
going on with the kid
what's going on with the family lots of
these kids are on the autistic spectrum
they have all sorts of secondary
comorbid
issues they're sort of
socially phobic they've got eating
disorders they may be depressed
and what she felt there should be a
thorough psychological investigation
as was the tavistock's tradition
into family dynamics individual psych
psychology and she felt that there was
too much of a willingness
to sort of go along with the kid in
terms of the kids idea
they've got there's one problem with one
solution
and they basically want to get through
past the gay
gatekeepers onto ucl
that's a generalized picture but it was
it was
a sort of predominant picture that was
being presented
so i'd say i was a part of the senior
management i said well what we would
usually do it's very multi-disciplinary
it's not like a traditionally medically
hierarchical
service you've got um lots of different
disciplines
and you're used to sort of discussing
and debating approaches
and i said well you've got to go back
and and challenge the culture
and she felt she was quite a senior
person by the time she'd arrived in this
service
this was was not welcome it was a sort
of shutting down
of any dissent or wish to
examine what was going on beneath the
surface for the kid
etc etc and she felt she got nowhere
do you have a sense of why that was
happening because
i imagine that people who work at the
tavistock particularly at a senior level
these are people who've been
in this field for a very long time i
imagine they all care about their
patients i imagine they all want the
best for the for the children that come
to the clinic
why would they not want feedback
about concerns about the well-being of
these children
do you think well i mean
the thing is is that um the tavistocks
are diverse places lots of different
departments and lots of different
cultures within those departments
um what i would say is that um
is that in a way what you had here was
as
it rapidly became apparent there was a
politicization of this whole area
so again unusually there was a very
close relationship with
mermaids and um with gender intelligence
the
the uh the track charities and they had
an unusual
sort of influence over the sort of
culture
um now i when i was in charge of the
adult and adolescent department i would
have
relationships with mind and some of the
charities
but they but they wouldn't sort of
insist on
the culture or look ask me to
run them by the protocols for treatment
et cetera et cetera
we're separate organizations my prime
responsibility
is thinking about the people that i'm
serving the the trainees
and the patients and looking after the
clinicians that's my prime
responsibility and other people
you've got voices that all feel they
should have some influence but you'd
have some distance from them
so you can keep your eye firmly on
thinking
about the psychological needs of the
patients you're treating
so this this sort of um this boundary
which was sort of
very sort of um you know
there's a sort of movement backwards and
forwards felt very unusual for me
so lots of unusual things going on and
um
and it produced i i thought a rather
not a clinical environment that i would
want to work in
marcus i find that very very shocking so
essentially you have a charity mermaids
which was not attached
to the clinic in any shape or form it's
not a regulated nhs body yet they were
having an influence
on the treatment of these children well
you know
they would argue not i i'd say you'd
always have stakeholders
so i've outlined who my prime
responsibility and then you've got your
stakeholders and they have some
influence
you know you're trying to address what
you know their concerns as well
um i would say that as stakeholders they
had an unusually
close relationship with the clinical
service
and my wife felt that began to
interfere with the ordinary clinical
environment in which
there would be debate discussion
challenge
about a particular treatment approach
you know this is what she would be used
to and and it
just wasn't happening in jids
so so what she did what we actually
discussed and what she did was
she was the first whistleblower in 2005
and um the medical director at the time
david taylor
set up a serious review of the service
he was on news night the other day
um because he he produced this report in
which he had recommendations he felt
that
the sort of clinical governance of this
experimental service was going off east
if you like
and there should be much more thorough
outcome measures
research looking at the downside of
treatment all
all sort of things that you would expect
particularly in an experimental
treatment with vulnerable kids
however he moved on as a medical
director
and not a lot changed after that initial
report
and marcus you use the word
politicization
within the clinic what do you mean by
that
well i think that once your sort of
um your decision making is based on a
sort of belief
a pre-existing belief structure may be
embedded within the clinicians
may be met by the parents and some of
the parents and some of the kids
you're not in a clinical environment you
see
lots of people you know will come into
psychiatry and they
when people are in a sort of chaotic
state of mind and they feel like their
minds are falling apart
they often focus down narrowly on
there's one problem with one solution
now psychological health is usually
based on the opposite
it's based on sort of opening things out
thinking that we're
complicated we've got many different
moving parts
as a personality and that usually
our problems are made up of all sorts of
things coming together so we're trying
to sort of open things out
for in ex for the kids for example
you're saying okay that's what you
believe
let's have a look at what's who you are
what's going on
beneath the surface what might be
troubling you let's
open this dialogue out so we think about
things in the round
um and you're you're not going along
with
um fixed beliefs there's one problem and
one solution
so just one more thing so one thing
that's often um
talked about is that the kid's
completely certain
well for me that's a red flag you know
that if you're making
very serious decisions you would expect
to have doubts
questions anxieties conflicts the
absence of those
is a problem you know and we believe
and we know as psychoanalysts you know
that beliefs
can be driven by all sorts of forces not
all of them
healthy or rational um now my job's not
to argue with the patient
my job is to say okay that's what you
think
and you feel distressed if you feel i'm
questioning that but my job is to open
things out as i said
and explore things um and
marcus i'm really glad that you brought
up because there's two points
i want to explore number one the
influence of social media
on kids and their desire to transition
and
number two the link between children who
want to transition and autism
yeah okay well you know when you're
coming up to adolescence you're very
preoccupied about the way you're seen
and social media has increased that
tenfold
so that we we're we really haven't
caught up
what effect social media is having on us
as individuals
and in terms of our relationships with
ourselves and with others
and um so in a way it's as if
the way i am is always now being judged
from how i look from the outside
well that's always been the case in
adolescence but now it's
increased tenfold and i think it's
problematic in lots of different ways in
more than just this area all sorts of
areas because we're partly
to be obsessed with the outside world
that's being a human
but we've also got to look out after the
soul i don't
i'm not religious in the size of i mean
what's going on inside you
but marcus aren't there also you know
websites in particular i think
pinterest was one that was being named
encouraging children to transition or
see themselves as trans
yeah there are websites that um
boast if you feel out on a limb a little
bit odd
like you don't fit in well that's
probably about 50 percent of adolescence
what your adolescence is like but i felt
like i was a sort of
square peg in a round hole you know
come join the site and then there's a
sort of
coaching kids are coached to get asked
the gatekeeping questions
um and sometimes you know the clinicians
say
that the kids are almost like they're
they're just speaking rotes
what they know the clinicians are right
you know so you've got a tick box
sort of scenario these are the questions
you'll be answered these are the answers
that they're looking for
[Music]
you know um so yeah it's all it's all
very worrying there's a
there's a cultish feel about about the
sort of
um the social media aspect of this so
effectively there's these
pages on on these social media websites
or websites themselves are effectively
grooming children
in order to transition yeah i mean
certainly you don't get a helpful
discourse about what the downside of
transition there's lots of downsides
of transition and often it looks like a
short-term solution to the
anxieties and problems problems of
puberty if we're thinking about
adolescence
but there's a long-term cost which isn't
spelt out
also transitioning is not easy it's not
easy psychologically it's not easy
socially
and it's not easy in terms of the impact
of
the medicalisation of your
your psychological problem you know
you've got to have ongoing hormones
if you have subsequently if you have uh
gender reassignment surgery the
surgery's got all sorts of implications
this is not an easy route and none of
that i think is being spelt out
in the uh i'm not an expert on the on
the website
but this is widely documented yeah
and marcus we'll come to that point in a
second but what i really want to explore
and then constantine by all means take
over
is easily between autism
and the children who wanting to
transition yeah so
so so the thing is my wife and i are
writing a book about psychological
approaches because we feel it's a sort
of vacuum
that's been neglected um and probably
what the tavistock should have been
concentrating on for the last 20 years
but basically you know if you've got
sort of fragile
um a kid with a fragile ego that doesn't
tolerate too much conflict or anxiety
i mean then that can be all of us we're
looking for ways of
getting rid of the psychological pain
as it were and sort of flattening the
mind if you like
and and um the autism
kids who are autistic or on the autistic
spectrum they struggle with conflict
anxiety and psychological pain
so they're very they're very attracted
to the sort of doctrine that says
basically the reason you're suffering is
because of x
if you do y you'll get rid of all your
problems and
you can flatten all this stuff that's
stirring you up and you know because
just
puberty is very important in this in
terms of the transition from being a
child
um often within a family or looked after
by a parent within a sort of structure
and you're transitioning into
getting an adult the hormones are going
to kick start your secondary sex
characteristics that's got all sorts of
implications for what sort of
role you're going to play in society
what sort of sexual role
what sort of adult you're going to be
you're transitioning from being a child
into an adult
expected to work a you know
have relations maybe have a family et
cetera et cetera so
all sorts of physical psychological and
social anxieties
get sort of stirred up by puberty
and in a way there's a wish to sort of
put the brake on
just sort of stop it the problem is if
you do
that you take the kid outside their
usual peer group and developmental
structure in which
all the kids are going through the same
thing and learning on the job as it were
um now that's what they said that was
the rationale sort of like a sort of
breathing space
but what we've sudden what we
subsequently just discover in the court
case it's not a breathing space
at all because ninety percent of the
kids who start on previously blockers
are on a medical conveyor belt which
doesn't stop
until cross-sex hormones etc
um so it is like trying to stop
an arrest a sort of natural
physiological and psychological and
sociological process
called puberty i was going to ask you
about that marcus because i mean it's a
strange question to ask someone whose
job it is to make
to help people improve their mental
health and well-being
but do you think this is part of a
broader thing in society where
we over pathologize and i would argue
certain
feelings for example yes if you're
trapped in in a perpetual cycle of deep
sadness we might describe that as
depression
that does not mean that experiencing
sadness for an hour or for a day or even
for a week in response to some really
difficult events in life is abnormal it
does not mean you need to you need
quote unquote help it just means
something's happened then you're
responding to it as a human would
but if we have a society which sort of
says the moment you feel anything
negative
we've got to treat you we've got to help
you then it's no surprise is it that
young children who are about to
experience as you say a very difficult
period of life
seeing that coming maybe starting to
experience bits of it go
i i need treatment i need medication i
need physical
help whatever it might be do you think
there's a part of that 100
i think that yeah look life is difficult
you know the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune
you know we're faced with all sorts of
psychological problems at every
you know every turn in life every part
of development so
and sometimes they're thrown at us like
covid and and
you know we're having to adapt but um i
think the sort of wish to describe
all these experiences being some sort of
mental health problem i think does a
disservice to mental health
and and is in danger of pathologizing
as you say a lot of quite normal
reactions
i i used to be um used to be in charge
of a liaison service in kings in the 80s
and a guy fell off um
he fell off a railway bridge and he
basically was paralyzed he lost the use
of his legs
and the nurses came down and referred
him to psychological medicine they said
he was depressed
and i thought i don't know what else
you'd be you know it's a completely
now i was sympathetic to them they were
overwhelmed don't get me wrong i didn't
send them away but i thought it was an
interesting word
it was quite appropriate you know if you
if you're paralyzed
you're going to be depressed but not in
a sort of um
pathological way in an ordinary way it's
part of mourning you know you're going
to have to come in terms of the loss
and i think you're right i think all
sorts of things are being captured
as as part of mental health actually
belong in
in in ordinary you know they're just
part of the slings and arrows outrageous
fortune
the other thing that goes along with
this is you see
when where there there are
um you've got to look at the the
influence i'm not against medication by
the way i'm not a psychoanalyst who's
against medication but
there is a tendency for the drug
companies to capture
sort of an increasing field say
adhd or depression or anxiety
and all of a sudden you're sort of more
and more people being
sort of trapped in that diagnosis for
which there is a pill
and then you know you go to the gp and
huge numbers of people are on
antidepressants
years ago they wouldn't have been called
depressed
they weren't suffering from what i knew
pound shillings and pence as
melancholia or psychotic depression for
which there's medication
you know they're they're unhappy they're
miserable they're lonely
et cetera et cetera that that's that's
not um
so in other words the what what's
captured in the diagnosis of depression
is
massively increased and it's related to
the new medications that have been
provided as i said i just want to
just reassure everyone i'm not against
medication it can be
very helpful but i i think sometimes
it's too
easy for us as psychiatric practitioners
to give a pill
um to what our ordinary psychological
problems of life
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own
you'd know about that move your domains
and websites over to easy dns right now
all you've got to do is head over to
easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like
france is talking to a woman so you have
to shout do you want to learn another
language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers
a clear and easy to use interface they
have daily 10 to 15 minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up
or maybe you're just english right now
babel is offering
our fans six months free on a six-month
subscription
with babel using our special code which
is of course
trigger that's babble b a b
b e l dot co dot u k
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babel dot co
dot uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
well it's interesting how this
conversation has gone be sort of outside
of the trans issue which is where we
started but i actually
really want to focus in on on this bit
of it which is
if someone is watching this and and then
maybe as we all do sometimes feeling sad
or upset or whatever is
how do you know the difference between
when you need
help with your mental health and you're
experiencing the
normal things that life will throw at
you and an actual
healthy unpleasant but yet healthy
response how do you know the difference
well when when yeah when it's
interfering and it's when your
depression is interfering in a
substantial way with your ability
to conduct your ordinary life
you know and um so we all have days when
we go up
with covid and i don't know about you
guys but sometimes you
get up and you just feel a bit blue but
you know
a sort of chat and uh you know you do
something you enjoy and you can pull
yourself out of it
someone who's suffering from depression
can't do that
you can't pull yourself out of it you
know you're
you need more than ordinary help to get
yourself out of feeling blue
and it interferes with your daily
functioning well
it's just i just thought it was an
interesting aside because i do feel that
having spoken with you and with many
others it ties into the trans issue it's
an attempt to
to deal with quite natural feelings that
it may be uncomfortable
and coming back to that issue what is
your explanation
for this what i think people need to
appreciate the extraordinary
transformation
of what you would describe as the
typical patient
in the last 30 or 40 years where you've
gone from
almost exclusively boys wanting to
become
women to where we are now which is
almost exclusively girls wanting to
transition how does that happen
i mean i'm not associated i think you've
got to sort of ask
sociologists and and um i mean
my view would be that there is a sort of
um a misogyny there's a sort of
it's attractive being sort of macho at
the moment you sort of get rid of your
feet the idea of a male
this is the interesting thing about the
ideology is it becomes more and more
rigid
you know if you look at some of the um
some of the stuff that stonewall put out
to
um children you know the gender
stereotypes are so rigid boys like
axemen
football girls like you know pink
fluffy dolls and and ballet
and um you know my
um my my sons didn't ever conform to
those stereotypes
um but you know and nor did i
in all sorts of complex ways so um
i think the attractiveness of some sort
of being some sort of figure
who gets rid of vulnerability doesn't
really worry about what other people
think is quite hard you know and all the
sort of softer side is projected into
women who's saying is
quite you know sensitive and in touch
with their emotions and that makes them
vulnerable to being hurt
now this isn't true this is just a
parody
of the gender stereotypes but
i think this ideology does create this
rigid division
and then people are very attracted to
getting rid of their emotions being a
tough guy
not really anyway i sort of feel i'm off
piste really because i
the the fact is as as the story unfolded
to go back to why i'm
here talking about this if i could for a
bit
yeah what what what then happened was my
wife left the service
and then the service carried on and i'd
hear as a manager about rumbles and
concerns from time to time but the
service got bigger and bigger and bigger
as the demand for
its clinical services increased and the
contract increased
um until now it's a very big part of the
tavistock it was
you know very small part of the
tavistock 20 25 years ago
um now it's a very big part of the
tavistock um
and what happened was when i took up
this voluntary position as governor
two things landed on the governor's desk
and as a governor
my job was to sort of oversee
is the trust doing what it's supposed to
be doing
um we're not part of management we're
just a sort of watchdog if you like
and two things came on the desk one was
a letter written by
ten parents whose kids were being
treated by
jids basically what they said it was a
very detailed letter
saying we had hoped our kids all got
complete problems
we'd hoped there'd be a thorough
psychological investigation et cetera et
cetera
that didn't happen we're we're not happy
we feel like our kids have been fast
tracked through to the medication so
that was one thing
then a colleague of mine dave bell he's
probably the best-known clinician in the
tavistock
um who was the staff governor previously
previous um we didn't overlap
i i started as governor he'd left
and basically he'd been approached by 10
members of staff from jids with very
similar concerns to the parents
so he'd done a report the trust knew
about
it and then the report was presented to
the trust board
i think that's right i think that's
right and of course
it was saying a lot of similar things
staff
felt the relationship with mermaids was
too close a lot of these kids that have
been transitioned have got secondary and
so quite co-morbid problems
um that there wasn't enough interest
in sort of debate and discussion within
the culture of the service et cetera et
cetera
what the trust did was they're very
unhappy about the report they wouldn't
let me see the report if i
despite the fact i said that i want to
see this report
if i'm going to adjudicate whether the
trust is doing his job i've got to see
all the materials
that was withheld so i thought that's
odd
why would you withhold that report
from a governor and there are other
governors that requested it as well
the second thing without was oh that's
right so then they set up
um the medical director was going to do
the trust report so several of us said
that's fine but we'd like dave
bell to be at the final hearing of the
report so
he can hear whether the medical
director's report
is addressing the concerns raised in by
the staff
no you can't so
a sort of i don't know um
it was quite a few emails went backwards
and forwards over a sort of six month
period
contesting this and and it was contested
when we met
and it appeared to me that the trust
wanted to use the medical director's
report to bury
the concerns about the service
and and i could see then the extent to
which
the trust and its management service was
politicized
i mean part of the reason is is that you
know that
the trust is dependent on legit service
with nhs england
as a stakeholder um
gender intelligence and mermaids
extremely influential it could put
influence on nhs england and
i began to think that the um
the political tale was wagging the
clinical dog
um anyway you know the battles continued
as it were
um and then to my shame
i actually voted through the medical
director's report
i actually sent round an article to all
of the governors saying
i thought that the the medical directors
felt
report fell short of answering
dave bell's question questions in in
quite a few key areas so i was unhappy
with the report
however i sort of voted it through along
with everyone else um
not very happy with myself um
marcus can i just ask why you did that
well because i thought they were trying
to take it
seriously what i didn't i wasn't sure
about was how
genuine they were in wanting to look at
what was going on beneath the surface
because that's what seemed
really difficult that was like a no-go
area
there's a belief system and it comes
back to the
another change it's as if this is no
longer a
mental health issue it is now a sort of
consumer issue
the child has chosen to transition
okay this moves it out of mental health
i never take the view that the anorexic
has
chosen to have anorexia and if they
don't want to eat they're going to start
after that that
you know that's my view is to try and
understand what's going on
it's not to sort of collude with that
but this seemed to be
a movement into sort of idea this was
the consumer choice
and i was dead against that so
i i went along with it and
not very happily and then the next day
the trust
put on the website basically
an article saying that the medical
director's report had been accepted
dave bell's report was basically
undermined
by virtue of the fact they said dave
bell had no expertise in this area
they didn't mention the fact that the
medical director had no expertise in it
either and the the the case studies were
all fictional
now i know dave he's as ethical as a day
as long he'd never fictionalized those
cases
so basically they're they're basically
trying to again
bury bury the concerns by attacking the
messenger
and at that point i knew that the trust
wasn't going to listen to me
and while i'm in the board of governors
i'd signed a confidentiality agreement
and in a way they got me where they
wanted me
which is inside the tent being very
unhappy but basically no one's listening
so i then resigned
and marcus now looking forward to the
kiera bell case
which uh she won can you explain
to people who may not have been
following that case or may not be based
in the uk
why that is such a landmark case now
yeah one or two steps in between just if
you
okay there was a posie parker set
something up at the house of lords
with lord mooney and um
there were hang on there were five of us
spoke
uh stephanie davis awry spoke about
education i spoke
um richard bing who's a gp professor
he spoke um michael laidlaw
endocrinologist from the states and the
woman from kelsey alliance
which is a family group from the states
the other interesting thing i'm learning
all the time here because
posy parker sent out invites to every mp
and every lord and basically one tory mp
arrived and tammy gray thompson
no one else arrived lord mooney had the
whip withdrawn
he'd been a labour party member for 40
years so i realized
he had to host the meeting but no one
would basically attend they've been
threatened
that they would have the wit withdrawn
if they attended and so that
the um as as james kirk has written
that the sort of silencing of opposition
in this area
you guys will be familiar with it is
unbelievable no one's allowed to have a
mind of their own or speak their own
voice as
as we saw with jk rowling um
subsequent to that meeting basically
um with a group of us met my wife
decided to take a judicial review with
mother a who is um
a woman who's got a gender dysphoric kid
autism she started the
my wife started the crowd justice
campaign and then
kiera bell stepped in um
basically because my wife and i could
have lost the house
if we'd lost because we'd have had to
pay our size damages and the other size
damages so
uh it was just too risky and kiera bell
obviously
being someone who's been through the
process was was the right person to take
the
the case to court finally the
implications are though
you know that when you when you looked
at i put in a witness statement
with the statement as did my wife and my
wife and
um the lawyer gathered
experts from all over the world in
autism
in endocrinology in neurodevelopment
psychology etc etc
it's an amazing group when you read
our size evidence against the tavistock
there's no comparison
we're talking about people with very
high profiles in their profession given
their considered opinion
backed up by a wealth of serious
research
against on the other side basically
you know political beliefs really backed
up by there's one study done in holland
in 2011
on 70 boys 20 of whom dropped out
um i mean there was no comparison
so yeah i mean but the case
the the the case is an amazing win
i think for sanity um
you know and it safeguards against um
early medicalisation of kids marcus
let me ask you this if i were an
uninitiated person who'd not been paying
attention to this issue in every way
and i were to take what you were saying
and i'd go okay so what you're telling
me is that senior medical
and psychiatric professionals basically
agree
that transitioning young children
shouldn't happen without
a full and exhaustive process and even
then it should be when they're 18 and
they're capable of consent
uh etc etc and yet the
the powers that be mps lords etc are so
terrified of
of supporting what you're doing that
they won't even come to a meeting
because they're gonna have the whipwood
drawn if i were looking
from the outside you'd go what what is
going on
right is there some kind of evil lizard
conspiracy to transition children
or what is it that's going to be the
title of the video by the way marcus
yeah i i'm um i'm not a conspiracy
theorist i've learned
so much about the power of um
[Music]
political forces in in our media
who's prepared to speak up who's not you
know
we set up a facebook page and basically
my wife and i are all about the evidence
for kids
that's all it is um that was taken down
because we vote for facebook rules i
mean
you know i don't get into the nastier
side of this very no
what can be very nasty argument um
we just present the clinical facts as it
were
so that was quite amazing to me my
twitter
um what's it banned as well
for similar reasons and you contact them
and you go why
because i'm not slagging anyone off i'm
not saying anybody should die or
anything like that i'd just
you know been sort of trying to get
support for
kiera bell in the case and
so yeah it's quite extraordinary what's
going on and sometimes when you
when you talk to people okay it can't be
as bad as you say it is
you must be i don't know you've lost the
plot
you you've hit a midlife crisis you're
angry with the tavistock
no it really is quite extraordinary
you know as a mental health practitioner
and someone who's proud to be in the
business that i mean
i'm really quite ashamed by you know the
lack of it this is political belief and
ideology
over rational scientific argument
and marcus i i think the thing is
that that we often forget about as well
is what the process of transition is
like well like we just applied the term
trans
and that suddenly people have this
transition and they go on and they live
their lives and everything's hunky-dory
but the reality
isn't really like that is it well that
was the legal argument you know
is an 11 year old capable of making
decisions about the implication a short
short term you know you know
um taking the medication which has got
long term
effects in terms of their development
and um yeah and and in which
really the downside of treatment is
never really spelt
out so so um kids would have so they
argued that 11 year olds were capable of
making these decisions
but then they'd have um sort of special
bits of information which were written
like sort of janet and john books
for simplicity so hang on you're saying
hang on them the kid's capable of making
complicated decisions but it's written
in this simplistic way
these two things don't add up it doesn't
add up with anything else that we think
about children i mean
think about the age of consent right
yeah
children can't consent to what may be
just
you know an activity that doesn't really
have any long-term consequences but you
know if there's no pregnancy
you know people had sex nothing really
happened you could argue
so they can't consent to that but what
they can consent to the age of 11 is
completely transforming their
hormonal balance and their physical body
that that does not
seem to match up to our current
standards for for treating children as
children does it
not at all no i mean you can't get a
tattoo to can you till you're 18.
it's also something can't do 18. no
this is there's a sort of non-think
about this area
you know it's like a sort of group
phenomena
in which you cannot challenge it you
know how
you get attacked as jk rowling did um
but b you know um
there's a sort of cultural look your
prejudice
this is all part of some paternalistic
plot to control
what other people do with their lives
never been my intention as a
psychoanalyst as a psychiatric
practitioner
to control people's lives apart from
you know when they're they're um you
know they need
sectioning and they're so psychotic that
their their actions may danger others or
themselves
apart from that at the end of the day my
my job as a psychoanalyst is help
individuals understand what's driving
them
so that they can make better decisions
about their lives
but i'm not trying to turn them into a
version of what marcus evans thinks they
should be
that's not my job um that's unethical in
my view
but that's how you're viewed this is
really some sort of
i've been called a christian right wing
bigger um i've sort of that's why we got
you on the show marcus
yeah i'm sort of
a little bit liberal with wishy-washy
and
i think the last time i went to church
my mother's horror
is when i was nine years old you know i
know actually i had to go to church i
was at boarding school so i had to go to
church so i was 15.
but um you know this is what gets
chunked at you
it is i think everybody knows that now
it's just an easy way to dismiss people
isn't it yeah uh
you know francis and i you know francis
is an old school lefty i'm a sort of
centrist
with quite libertarian views but uh
people will assume
if you care about you know children not
getting their breasts life stuff at the
age of 14
that that means you're a right-wing
bigot well maybe maybe we should be all
right-winged bigots on that basis
shouldn't we
i mean the thing is is sort of
you're in alliances with all sorts of
people that i never thought i would be
so um i had a long discussion with
panorama about going on the first
panorama which was exposing kids and
they said
look we need we can't get anybody to go
in front of the camera and as a
psychologist i didn't want to
because you know because i've got
patience and you know your job as a
psychoanalyst is to be in the background
unfortunately i've broken those rules
for my the people that i see
but um but basically
i i watched the effect of the fact that
polly carmichael kept saying you know
these kids are safe in their hands and
we're very you know
measured in what we do and i knew that
wasn't
the case and i was furious with myself
for not going on panorama so the daily
mail contacted me
and said we'll do a piece you can tell
your story
and of course all the broad sheets
they'll give you a sort of quote
but they won't let you tell your story
so so i was doing an interview with the
daily
daily mail which i and the daily well
were
actually absolutely down the line on
this
they were they were very thorough they
were very professional and they knew all
about it and i was very grateful to them
but i'd never imagined myself doing an
interview with the daily mail
until this so yeah life's taking a funny
turn
and marcus why do you think this issue
is so toxic because it seems to me
for the vast majority of people if you
ask them about it
they would be entirely in agreement with
everybody here in this discussion
why is it that it descends into name
calling
you know people getting you know
threatened abused etc etc
well i think i think we've become again
i think it goes back to your
earlier point constantine we've become
obsessed by people's feelings
now as a psychoanalyst i'm here to say
things are very important
but but also the objective mind is
important
and we've got this out of characters out
of balance so that
you know if someone's traumatized by
what you're saying
because they feel hurt well that's part
of the story but
but we should also be interested in
thoughts and facts and reason you know
we we need both
and at the moment our discourse seems to
be dominated by
what people feel um and as i say just to
say as a psychologist i
you know i'm i'm listening all day to
what people feel
but i also want to know what people
think
you know we've got to use our minds as
well as our hearts
and sorry i've i don't know if i've lost
your question
there france no no no no it was no no i
i it was a very it's a very very good
point you know that we become
obsessed with people's feelings we
become obsessed we you know with what
not wanting to hurt or offend people
but there also is something
unfortunately called objective reality
absolutely you know and if you've got an
11 year old girl or boy and you're you
know you're
slicing off parts of their genitalia
because of feelings
you need somebody to go well hang on a
minute here we need to look into this
the thing is is that you know that there
was a long history wasn't it
and um prejudice in this sort of area
and it's as if this sort of as
piggybacked
on on that bad history and now
nobody wants to be seen as being
prejudiced
the problem with that is it's like
judgment
has also been lost in the process
because i would say there's a difference
between judgmentalism
and judgment we need judgment
we need to be wary of judgmentalism and
and we need to start
separating these things out and being
able to you know freedom of thought and
freedom of discourse is so
important for us as individuals you know
so a person comes to me and says i'm
absolutely sure i'm x
and my job isn't to butt heads with them
but it is to say
well hang on i wonder why you
you're so fixated on this belief
and why you have to drum that into me
that i can't challenge it because sort
of tyrannical states of mind
again a psychoanalyst you're sort of
wary of you sort of think well hang on a
minute what's driving this and why
can't you why can't we examine this area
because you know most most of the time
we know that sort of when we're in a
healthy state
you know you're not so defensive you can
have things examined and looked at from
different points of view but when you
become
fanatical it's usually being driven by
something
else and that's my job as a
psychoanalyst is trying to understand
what that is
yeah and marcus one question that i
really wanted to ask you so i'll tell
you so i was a teacher for 12 years
regular viewers
and listen to the podcast have a drink
now um and one of my colleagues i
remember she came to me absolutely
distressed in floods of tears to tell me
that
her eleven-year-old daughter told her
that she
wanted to transition and she used the
words not if i transition when i
transition
and this is an 11 year old girl what
would your advice be as
a mental health practitioner to
that woman in particular and to scores
of parents up and down the country
who are dealing with this particular
issue well i certainly think
right okay so there's several levels for
this one is at the school
level that you know if there is
um you've got to find out who's teaching
what
and are you happy with what's being
taught and i would sort of
you know parents need to get organized
around this
and and some parent parental groups have
got wise to the fact
that their kids are being taught things
which
you know are part of a sort of political
doctrine
and then i'd you know that that needs to
be addressed and there's a
and stephanie davis awry runs a website
called
transgender trend which has been sort of
helping parents
sort of get to know what's going on and
there are materials in which you can
present the headmistress or headmaster
or whatever and challenge that
at a sort of individual level if you've
got a partner
um you know you've got to sort of get on
the same page off this
this problem often drives a wedge
between
the parents which again is very
unhelpful
um you've got to have a sort of serious
sort of thrash out of where you're
coming from and what the approach might
be
but for me i i would say
you know you're trying to what you do
with
with adolescents when they get a b in
their bullet about something
you know you're trying to sort of have a
think about
what they're like in the round you know
as a personality are they struggling in
a particular area how do they measure up
against their brother and sister
are they struggling at school think
about them as a person
across the board because kids often
you focus on one thing and the problem
area is somewhere else
and you don't want to get into the
arguments if you if you can you know
sometimes you've got to stand up to your
kids
you know and say well hang on you know
we need to slow this down
and i'm not being bullied into anything
and
i'd certainly be prepared to do that but
then
i was trying to think about them and
think about as i say
what what what's going off for them off
off camera if you like
as well as you know everyone's attention
is
is is sort of drawn to the area of
conflict
and that's often not what's driving the
problem as it were so
then you've got a problem of trying to
get um
mental health practitioners who've
there's been a sort of enormous policy
capture into this area where
you've got the affirmation model which
was adopted
with virtually no evidence and
jettison in um what used to be in place
was what's called watchful waiting
which is that gender dysphoric kids
you know most of them would desist if
supported and left of their own devices
um there's a sort of huge capture
of of the clinical environment um
so then you've got to find you've got to
be wise and you've got to find
clinicians who are not going to
automatically
affirm if you think they need clinical
help but someone who's prepared to say
i'm a general child psychotherapist
psychologist and i will look at your kid
in the hole
take into consideration you know coma
will be problems etcetera etcetera get
to know them
and we're not making any quick decisions
sorry
a long spiel but that's no you know no
no marcus
it's great advice and i i think it's an
issue
actually that that terrifies a lot of
parents a lot of people won't
speak up on him but there are plenty of
people who don't even have children yet
who are thinking
or when i do have a child is this the
thing
that they're gonna go to school and get
brainwashed and there was a story in the
papers today from eaton of all places
where they're teaching them transgender
ideology and all this sort of stuff so
it seems to be very widespread in the
educational system can i just say one
one more thing the ideology divides
basically guys the generations you hear
we have parents who contact my wife and
i
going they don't trust the services my
kid wants to transition
you know we're in an argument with it so
divides the generations it sometimes
divides
the parents you know dad's four
mums against and this can actually split
up
couples no in my house mate my wife
would
destroy anyone who tried to go near it
it guides the mind from the body
you know because actually this is a
problem in the mind and it's related to
all the changes that are going on in the
body so you know it's
it's a very divisive area and uh we
needed to sort of bring
fine links and bring things together and
it creates so much division
um and pain because of it thank you for
that cherry ending to the interview
marcus
brilliant uh but listen we've got one
more question for you and
by the way thank you so much for coming
on the show it has been a genuine
pleasure speaking with you
and our last questions always is what is
one thing we're not talking about as a
society but we really should be
well i i think it's related to what
we've been dis
discussing i think it's the closing down
of the discussion
and debate which is you know
it's such bad news and um
it's bad news individually we all need
to be challenged and we live in an
environment
you see this idea you could define who
you are your identity is partly formed
by who you
you are but it's also in negotiation
with the external world
and you know we've sort of lost sight of
that
sort of um dynamic if you like we we
live in relation to the external world
we don't have the right to say this is
me and
you know you've got to accept it and if
you don't i'll scream and shout at you
you know
other people have got their own minds
they're entitled to have a view
including what they think of you and
this is important for individual
psychology and psychological health and
it's
important for democracy spoken like a
true bigot thank you marcus
marcus thank you so much for coming on
we'll make sure to put your details
in the description of the video thank
you everybody for watching we'll see you
very soon
with another interview or a live stream
all of them go out at 7pm uk time
episodes go out on wednesday and sunday
live streams on tuesday
thursday friday and saturday see you
soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word